♪♪
>> GOOD FRIEND RIVIERIA.
WE'RE LEARNING MORE IMMIGRATION
ABOUT THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
THAT THE MAYOR IS TRYING TO
PROTECT FROM FOLLOWING THE LAW
AND FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
AUTHORITIES.
ACCORDING TO THE L.A. TIMES OF
THE 232 PEOPLE ARRESTED IN THE
LATEST CRACKDOWN IN CALIFORNIA,
180 WERE EITHER CONVICTED
CRIMINALS, HAD BEEN ISSUED A
FINAL ORDER OF REMOVAL OR
PREVIOUSLY REMOVED FROM THE
UNITED STATES.
115 HAD PRIOR FELONY CONVICTIONS
TO SERIOUS INNINGS.
HERE NOW WITH MORE, NATIONAL
SECURITY STRATEGIST.
YOU KNOW, IF YOU'RE GOING TO --
THE LAW OF THE LAND IS THE LAW
OF THE LAND.
CHANGE THE LAW, CHANGE THE LAW.
BUT WHEN YOU ARE AIDING AND
ABETTING, ESPECIALLY THE PEOPLE
WHO YOU'RE LOOKING FOR, CRIMINAL
ALIENS THAT COMMITTED CRIMES IN
THE COUNTRY, YOU'RE PUTTING
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN JEP
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN JE
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN FE
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN FEAR
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN FEAR.
>> I KNOW I'VE BEEN OUT OF SYNC
WITH WITH THE MAJORITY OF THE
VIEWERS FOR THE YEARS I'VE BEEN
HERE.
I APOLOGIZE.
>> DON'T EVER APOLOGIZE.
>> I AS A STUDENT OF HISTORY
RECALL LEARNING ABOUT THE --
ABOUT THE COMPROMISE OF 1850,
THE FUGITIVE SLAVE ACT.
THE OFFICIALS HAD THE FREE
STATES WERE REQUIRED TO HELP
RETURN THEM TO THE SLAVE OWNERS
IN THE SOUTH.
THE PEOPLE IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
LOS ANGELES SEE THIS MOVE AS
UNDOCUMENTED MOVEMENT IN THAT
LIGHT.
>> THEY'RE GOING AFTER KNOWN
CRIMINALS.
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
WE PUT THEM UP.
>> YOU GAVE THE EXAMPLE OF 232.
I GRANT YOU THERE WERE -- THERE
WERE REAL CRIMINALS.
>> THAT'S WHO IS TARGETED NOW.
>> THE POINT -- THIS IS NOT ME,
THIS IS THE MAYOR OF OAKLAND
SAYING, THAT'S A COMMUNITY WHERE
THE CRIME DROPPED THREE STRAIGHT
YEARS OF LAW-ABIDING IMGRANTS
WHO DESERVE TO LIVE FREE.
>> WITHOUT DEPORTATION.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
OTHERWISE LAW-ABIDING.
STILL PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T RESPECT
OUR LAWS.
THAT'S NOT WHO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE.
>> WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
SLAVES BEING RECAPTURED.
THE ANALOGY IS INCORRECT.
THESE ARE CRIMINALS.
IF YOU CAME HERE ILLEGALLY
YOU'RE CRIMINAL.
MORE THAN 100 PEOPLE CONVICTED,
NOT SUSPECTED OF CRIMES.
CONVICTED OF VIOLENT FELONIES IN
AMERICA.
>> DR. GORKA, ISN'T THAT
DECISION, WHETHER OR NOT TO
CREATE A SANCTUARY, ISN'T THAT
FOR THAT CITY TO DECIDE?
>> NO.
WHEN THE FOUNDING FATHERS
CREATED A FEDERAL SYSTEM, THEY
SAID THE PRESIDENT.
>> STATES RIGHTS?
>> NO.
IMMIGRATION HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE STATES.
THE NATIONAL BORDER IS NOT
AROUND CALIFORNIA.
>> THAT'S WHY THEY'RE SAYING
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ASSIST YOU.
>> WE'RE NOT GOING TO ASSIST
YOU.
>> IMMIGRATION IS IN THE
CONTROL OF THE EXECUTIVE.
NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
>> CONTROL IMMIGRATION.
THEY DON'T.
>> POINTING TO A CASE OF A MOM
WHO HAS BEEN IN COUNTRY FOR 26
YEARS, FOUR CITIZEN CHILDREN,
LAW-ABIDING.
THEY WERE CAPTURED AND DEPORTED.
HE GOES OUT.
THEY TAKE JUAN AND MARIA.
THEY TAKE THE DISHWASHER AND THE
LAWN MOWER AND THE BABYSITTER.
THEY DON'T TAKE THE MS13.
>> THERE'S A REASON OF THE
STATUE OF JUSTICE IN EVERY
COURTROOM IN AMERICA IS
BLINDFOLDED.
IT DOESN'T LOOK AT WHO YOU ARE.
IF YOU BROKE A LAW, YOU'RE A
CRIMINAL.
IF YOUR NAME IS CLINTON YOU
DON'T GET A PASS.
>> YOU'RE CONFUSING PEOPLE.
>> NO.
>> BY CALLING THEM CRIMINALS
WHEN THE ONLY CRIME THEY BROKE
IS THEIR PRESENCE IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> BREAKING THE LAW.
>> THEY HAVEN'T MURDERED OR
THIEVED.
>> MANY OF THEM HAVE.
>> 100 OF THE OF 230.
BUT HUNDREDS OF OTHERS.
THIS MAYOR IS IN THE IN TROUBLE
SHE TOLD ME.
>> WHAT LEVEL OF THE WHITE
HOUSE AND THEY'RE LOOKING INTO
LEGAL ACTION AGAINST THE MAYOR.
>> AIDING AND ABETTING.
>> SCUTTLEBUTT AND SHE
ANNOUNCED IT.
>> SHE'S TIPPING OFF THOSE
PEOPLE.
PEOPLE I GET IT OFFENDS PEOPLE
BUT NOT ILLEGAL.
>> NOW YOU SOUND LIKE BILL
CLINTON.
I GOT THE INFORMATION FROM HERE.
>> UNPOPULAR MOVE BY THE MAYOR
IN HER COMMUNITY.
CRAZY CALIFORNIA BUT IT IS -- IT
IS THE SIXTH LARGEst COUNTRY.
>> I GOT --
>> IT IS -- IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHERE YOU GET THE INFORMATION.
IT IS A CRIME.
>> ALIENS THAT WOULD HAVE
OTHERWISE BEEN DEPORTED.
WOULD SOMEBODY HAVE BLOOD ON
THEIR HANDS THAT THEY ASSISTED
IN -- IN [INDISCERNIBLE].
NOT IF THEN.
YOU THOUGH WHAT PEOPLE WITH
VIOLENT CRIMES DO IT AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
HANDFUL OF CASES.
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS.
>> WHY WOULD IVANKA MEET WITH
YOU?
>> I WAS AT MAR LAGO AND WAS
THERE WITH THE FAMILY, AND I WAS
VERY CLOSE.
IVANKA AND I DO CELEBRITY
APPRENTICE.
SHE REACHED OUT AND SAID LET'S
HAVE TEA.
I SAID -- SHE HAD COFFEE I HAD
WATER.
I WAS UPSTAIRS WITH IVANKA.
WE TALKED ABOUT --
>> THIS IS -- THIS IS SUCH A
BETTER SELFIE THAN WHAT I'M USED
TO.
KIDDING.
JARRED WAS ON HIS WAY OUT.
>> YOU TALKED ABOUT THE PEOPLE
IN DC THAT WERE HORRIBLE.
>> SHE'S SO NOBLE AND SO
EFFICIENT AND SO EFFECTIVE.
SHE WANTS THE BEST FOR THE
COUNTRY.
SHE WANTS THE BEST FOR HER DAD.
I'M 100 PERCENT BEHIND HER.
SHE AND -- THE KIDS ARE SETTLED.